I get asked a lot, "How do you patent an idea?"
And I read a terrific book called "Patent It Yourself."
Fantastic book, very straightforward and I wrote GoPro's first patent.
And the 60-page tome that I went maniacal on, and then, when I took it to attorneys...
...to get their opinion on it, they told me that I saved a ton of money...
...because I have done all this work myself and they could polish it up...
...and finish it off.
And so, I save myself a bunch of money but more importantly it gave me an understanding of...
...what is patentable and what not.
And I think any entrepreneur that is inventing something, that book is phenomenal.
That's, I think, the only book that I read...
...was "Patent It Yourself."